place la séance est ouverte lors du jeu
rappelle les questions au gouvernement
la parole est au président christian
jacob
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre monsieur
le premier ministre vous êtes au pouvoir
depuis trois ans
depuis trois ans vous n'avez jamais pris
la mesure du caractère stratégique de
l'agriculture
il n'y a pas d'industrie agroalimentaire
sans une agriculture forte en france je
vous le rappelle un actif sur cinq
travaille dans cette filière depuis six
mois
la crise couve vous avez semé la tempête
en restant in her passif
je dirais même inexistant et ne nous
parlez pas de votre plan de 600 millions
d'euros
c'est une opération de les hommes c'est
une mascarade
c'est un mensonge ce sera même
vraisemblablement une fumisterie
monsieur premiers matches à l'euro c'est
l'europe les critères d'utilisation de
ces 600 millions seront tels qu'à
l'arrivée il durera que quelques
dizaines de millions qui seront utilisés
ne me dit pas non plus que tout vient la
lme la lme c'était il ya sept ans
qu'avez vous fait depuis le contexte a
complètement changé les républicains
aujourd'hui monsieur le premier ministre
vous demande un moratoire sur la mise
aux normes des bâtiments d'élevage des
mesures immédiates de baisse des taux
d'intérêt et d'étalement des prêts ce
que nous avons fait pour la grèce nous
le devons aux paysans de france
un partage des marges au sein de la
filière
parce que le seul dans le travail n'est
pas respectée aujourd'hui c'est le
producteur et enfin monsieur le premier
ministre
une mobilisation européenne puissante
pour lutter contre les distorsions de
concurrence des pays qui ne respectent
ni les normes sociales ni les normes
environnementales
mais pour cela il nous faudrait un
ministre digne de ce nom
un ministre qui arrive
le tour des capitales repère un ministre
qui par sont en rupture allait cibler
interne du parti socialiste maire ce
monsieur le premier ministre
merci le seul précédent ou du rouleau
ils attendent de vous des décisions la
parole et à monsieur le ministre malien
de la culture
et vous monsieur le premier ministre à
vous monsieur le président à léo sur le
président jacob je vous réponds vous
êtes président de groupe
le ministre de l'agriculture aura
l'occasion puisqu'il ya de nombreuses
il y aura de nombreuses questions sur ce
sujet là le monde agricole le monde de
l'élevage traverse une crise importante
elle n'est pas nouvelle
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
le monde agricole pas tout le monde
agricole mais une partie traverse depuis
longtemps une crise qu'on peut qualifier
d' économique social et même morale il y
à de l' angoisse de la détresse de la
colère chacun peut le constater
et ce message l'avons entendu déjà
depuis longtemps et c'est tout le sens
de l'action que nous menons depuis 2012
avec la loi sur l'avenir de
l'agriculture et le chef de l'état le
gouvernement le ministre de
l'agriculture l'entendent et être
éleveur vous savez vous connaissez ces
sujets monsieur jacob
ça veut pas dire que vos diagnostics
quel bon mais c'est un métier difficile
c'est une volonté d'entreprendre prendre
des risques c'est travailler sans
compter et sans compter sur l'engagement
au détriment de sa vie tout simplement
et de sa vie familiale
monsieur le président face à cette
détresse
les vociférations les mises en cause
personnelles et notamment celle du
ministre de la culture ne sont pas
dignes monsieur jacob et ne sont pas à
la hauteur de la situation et
précisément vu les responsabilités que
vous avez exercé dans ce domaine là cela
mériterait puisque vous êtes président
de groupe de ce maître mais vous en ai
pas capable monsieur jacob à la hauteur
de la situation
l'adresse des animaux fleurs on enlève à
des fins politiciennes et je comprends
monsieur jacob que vous n'ayez pas envie
qu'on revienne sur le passé et bien vous
allez en souffrir on peut y revenir
la loi de modernisation de l'économie
que vous avez porté aveuglement nous en
payons les conséquences aujourd'hui
la fin des quotas laitiers que vous avez
acheté en 2008
nous en payons les conséquences
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui monsieur
jacob et je peux le dire aussi à
monsieur le maire le monde paysan n'a
pas besoin d'exploitation politicienne
n'a pas besoin de récupération comme
vous êtes en train de le faire mais il a
besoin d'avoir des solutions durables
dans l'avenir et d'avoir de nouveau
confiance dans l'avenir et c'est cela
que nous devons à tous les agriculteurs
et notamment aux jeunes et à ceux qui
ont fait le choix d'investir dans cette
filière parce que nous considérons que
l'agriculture est non seulement au coeur
de l'identité de notre pays que l'on
seulement l'agriculture et notamment
l'élevage sont des filières d'avenir
mais que c'est au coeur même de
l'économie d'aujourd'hui et de demain
alors le gouvernement est aux côtés des
éleveurs et nous avons deux réponses
une qui répond précisément à l'urgence
et l'autre au moyen et long terme et qui
est une réponse structurelle
ce plan qui a été détaillé ce matin par
le ministre de l'agriculture mais
monsieur jacob mais quel mépris
quelle manière de faire de la politique
quelle manière et quel type de langage
vous utilisez la manière dont vous
parlez jamais je n'oserais parler qu'un
responsable de l'opposition de cette
manière
jamais vous avez été ministre de la
république est-ce que vous rendez compte
de la manière dont vous êtes adressé un
autre ministre de la république
mais enfin monsieur jacob la manière
dont vous parlez c'est une manière qui
déconsidère l'action et le langage
politique pardon de vous lire
mais ça n'est pas encore une fois dit la
députée de la république et la
présidente de vaux sur des sujets pareil
enfin est ce que vous vous rendez pas
compte
monsieur jacob que traverse ses propos à
travers cette attitude
à travers ce qu'ils attaquent ce n'est
pas vous qui vous aimez ce ne sont pas
vous amical et très et se le prendre sur
soi très populiste
vous êtes en train une nouvelle croix
enfin monsieur jacob rendez vous compte
de vos propres responsabilités
six axes sont au coeur des propositions
qui ont été détaillées par le ministre
la culture et moi j'entends ce que
disent les adducteurs depuis tout à
l'heure et ils sont en train de se
rendre connu le gouvernement répond
précisément alors attendent le
redressement des prix payés aux éleveurs
la restructuration des dettes les
allégements lé report des charges
comment voulez-vous parler de mesurettes
et de quelque chose qui ne
correspondraient pas à la réalité
c'est cette urgence qui a tendu que
demande monsieur jacob puisque vous
parler en leur nom
les agriculteurs précisément qu'on
réponde aux problèmes de la dette et de
la structuration de la dette ce sont des
mots qui l'ont utilisé hier à l'occasion
de la rencontre avec le ministre et vous
pour des raisons politiciennes
parce que vous êtes dans l'opposition la
plus totale et la plus absurde vous ne
reconnaissez pas que ce plan va dans le
bon sens et puis trois axes qui vont
dans le sens du moyen et du long terme
avec le développement de la
contractualisation dans les filières
d'ailleurs monsieur le maire avait
commencé sur ce dossier là parce que
nous sur ces sujets là nous considérons
que face aux difficultés
on peut reconnaître quand les choses
vont dans le bon sens deuxièmement les
actions pour développer les débouchés à
l'exportation
enfin si vous aviez tout régler si vous
aviez tout mené on n'en serait peut-être
pas là non plus et enfin l'amélioration
de la compétitivité des filières et je
n'oublie pas bien sur la simplification
sur tous ces sujets là le dialogue la
discussion vont se poursuivre encore ses
tables après midi avec la filière bovine
avec le ministre de la culture avec le
ministre l'économie avec communiste du
commerce extérieur nous sommes mobilisés
tous pour trouver les solutions de court
terme pour trouver des solutions
structurelles
le pays a besoin de cette filière c'est
un message de confiance
nous voulons construire nous voulons
construire l'avenir monsieur jacob
si vous étiez responsable vous serez
avec nous vous ne l'êtes pas mais nous
nous continuons à agir
merci monsieur le premier ministre